we were back here watching and they were
in tears you were in tears we couldn't
hear every word but tell me why that was
such an emotional exchange because they
knew me when it was dreams just for all
of us we were all dreamers we were
dreaming the same dreams in that fact
that I get to be here we're in the same
journey together and we're getting to
experience the same thing and it's so
humbling because you can't win the race
if you're not in it and that's what
people need to remember you can't just
give up on your dreams you have to fight
hard for them even if it takes 20 years
to see them realize what has their
friendship meant to you through all the
ups and downs um when you have your
tribe of people you realize that the
downs are though the ups outweigh the
downs and and they're my tribe I don't
know how did you guys originally meet I
didn't know that this friendship was so
long
well they that I I met them through my
friend Tate Taylor they were all in the
growlings classes together and you know
it was wonderful to go out and support
them I didn't know them but I I knew
because I got introduces all of them
early on what their talents would bear
and here we are I know you and Melissa
are maybe working on a movie together
right when are we can we Ben wrote and
he and Melissa produced and Melissa
stars in it thunderforce about two women
who happen to be our age are superheroes
so there you go are we gonna get are we
already here you gave Brad Pitt a little
shout out he's sitting right there in
the front row of course they put Brad
Pitt somebody who's getting an honor
tonight two of you guys just exchanged
any words I'm like kind of both getting
honored tonight and what this night
means to you well I think Brad Pitt and
Dee Dee and Jeremy they figured it out
they've picked projects that
have influenced us and introduced us to
diverse storytelling storytellers and as
my company grows I want to do the same
so I am so excited for all of tonight's
nominees and honorees but especially
them last question for you were sick
during the Globes right we missed you I
I was sick during the Globes
well today is my first day out of bed
and out of the beer yeah well I it's
literally like it when it went away it
really went away but it literally didn't
go away for a couple days which is why I
did not want to breathe out yet question
is what happened to the Globes dress
will you get to wear it on a different
you're seeing the eye I didn't I don't
always do dresses you're saying the top
of the tuxedo and I decided to you know
I had to repurpose it because it was too
good to waste
you know what perfect for a night where
you are getting an honor I love it thank
you thank you so much
[Music]